everybody digs the song man so when are
we gonna rehearse when did you get into
town yesterday did you I think yeah
influence we share II flew in for our
rehearsal was your girlfriend sitting
out there Oh was she come in she'll come
in Cherie come on in babe oh wow look at
sherry nice outfit
wow you're tall - how tall you sherry
I seriously Rob you think I'm too tall
for the band special shoes to equalise
yeah right so good you need to have
special shoes Howard Rob's not kidding
about the shoes you should see what he's
wearing let me say I'm shoes how me and
Charlie bought the great equalizers let
me say do me a favor help me out because
I'm gonna play the song now what are you
saying you just tell me what I'm
supposed to be saying you should have
came to rehearsal nope I'm going without
me I gotta be at my best put the song on
and let's see what you're gonna do all
right this is the edited version I'm by
the way to have we decided if we're
gonna say the f-word on stage or should
we just not say her it's gonna slip it
might slip yeah all right
[Music]
[Applause]
sitting here with Rob new supergroup was
formed just a couple of months ago did
you guys come up with a name yes except
we can't say it on radio it's like the
song we can't see half of it on the
radio no now the group can't be
mentioned anywhere this is the great Rob
Zombie doing
our song can the fiber part soundtrack
you got the premiere tonight everyone I
spoke to said they now can't listen to
the song without hearing you going
that's that's Rob I'm so proud of my
singing yeah I mean that I'm actually in
key and everything I'm anxious to
perform tonight I just hope I you know I
don't let you down
what do you say would you say 13 ghosts
in the devil's head is that what I said
yeah you know remember 13 ghosts in The
Devil's head like 45 times what is that
never done what did I say what's the
whole line
I don't know hardcore love hardcore
never dead
that's so come in you're a sick bastard
all right but never did you know when
Rob first showed me Butler is like
what's wrong with him look at that see
what my special man hardcore love of the
never dead do you need a cue card girl
yeah there you go
hey who you calling girl band mate don't
put me down
I know this part call me the American
dream American dream
[Music]
I know you were I think I'm gonna change
the law you can change it all right
that's great
oh me we'll go with anything in the ball
your soul corruptor doesn't sound like
collector at all all right so I forgot
what I said I wasn't concentrating in
the words France and let's agree what
are we gonna say we can't say the F word
every minute the bleep is on me and
Charlie's girlfriend they're gonna
scream it from off the side so maybe
I'll get onto Mike that way you guys
want to know what I'm thinking is that
on MTV they're gonna end up bleep in it
maybe at the end we'll just say once get
on a roll well you better work that out
I'll just go yeah yeah I like it yeah
yeah yeah when did you start running my
groove out of the studio Robin I'll
break up the bed
what do I have to say yeah you know at
least you're more help than Rob what do
I say yeah yeah yeah yeah just like echo
[Music]
I can do that yeah yeah
[Applause]
I'll just do a lot of that
hey now I'll just say hey now hey now
hey now
I don't care about that that's Rob Klein
what do they sound like I don't know I
don't know what I just said about my
head I just think I'm gonna keep saying
30 I think you keep saying 13 goes from
the devil made every line wait can you
rewind you don't even know what I know
what is what does it say lust and death
Oh what do I say gone something
something less than death less than
death gone in your head gone in your
head lost I'm not in your head gone in
your head whatever I'm telling you man
bring out the pointer you know I'm sorry
okay we made a good song all right
that bouncing ball like a mother
now what am I saying their degeneration
how much is the sound guy gonna know to
hit me into robot sound effect yeah or
Battlestar Galactica Lara yeah I can't
do that without a Ted has all those
special effects exact what do I say
their right mind degenerating yeah you
sing this my pack mine degenerated
that's the best just wish I was up to it
rap hack mind and the generator of
course I do I'm in a band I just know I
know what it's about
he feels it right pack mind D generator
[Music]
King ghosts in the body sing the body
sing the body what right red yeah how do
you know these Larry sherry because I
love this song no but I mean I don't
care how much you love it she gets used
to them you see the bodies I mumble but
what about my singing yours I understand
I got a right next to that whisper that
that line sounds a little bit like Alan
Alda wanted fresh battery do you who do
you need no it's hopeless I'm gonna be
posing a lot just be like you know I'm
gonna do a thing like you know kind of
like this is why it's all live no tape
all right anyway Rob will be there
tonight at the pier
we don't know what he'd be performing I
know that rock one of us will be
performing